So I told you yesterday about the latest evidence
that Donald Trump completely and totally does
not understand tariff
sort of like at a fundamental, very, very
basic level, but that that lack of understanding
doesn't stop him from adding tariffs to China,
uh, on Chinese goods, which of course as I
explained yesterday, are actually paid by
American companies and by American consumers.
And we seem now to have crossed over into
actual market panic and volatility as a result
of Donald Trump's completely misguided and
harebrained economic policy when it comes
to tariffs and China. And yesterday, stocks
were tumbling. I don't do much day to day
stock market coverage on this show. We tend
to take a big picture view, but the reaction
and the chaos around Trump's tariffs is important.
And I have to talk about it. We saw the Dow
Jones industrial average dropped a little
over 600 points are around almost 3%. We saw
a massive drop in the Nasdaq. We saw a massive
drop in the s and p 500, which is the broader
of those three major indices.
And this is all because of this escalating
trade war that Donald Trump is waging against
China without understanding a thing about
economics, without knowing anything about
trade and it's getting worse and worse and
very likely today, stocks will rebound as
is often the case after these major, major
drops and people write to me and they'll say,
David stocks dropped yesterday, but they recovered
today. Well, more than likely, uh, you'll
know by the time you watch or listen to this,
uh, uh, which would because the trading day
is still happening today. The recovery today
will not be as big as the massive drop yesterday,
but the point is the massive volatility day
to day that the president's misguided policies
are causing. And I'm going to show you a quote
that tells us just how truly ignorant Donald
Trump is on this issue of tariffs. He said
yesterday to White House reporters.
We've never taken in 10 cents from China until
I was elected. We're taking in billions of
dollars in tariffs. I love the position that
we are in. We've gone up a lot since our great
election. What it means for our country to
go up a lot, uh, is, is very dumb and childish
and stupid. But the fundamental misunderstanding
is that China doesn't pay the tariffs. The
money that Trump is talking about taking in
is coming from American companies and American
people who are paying the tariffs. This is
a dangerous man who doesn't understand fundamentally
basic. This is weaponized ignorance. Stocks
are crashing, trumps add chair, uh, Trump
ads, tariffs to China, China adds terrace,
Trump ads, more terrorists. And then the whole
circle sort of starts again and again. And
meanwhile, China forges other relationships
while our companies and our people get screwed.
So I'm going to try another approach on this
today because there's lots of people who are
apparently as confused as Trump is on this
issue because I get emails from people saying,
David, you're against tariffs.
So you're a pro free trade guy. Free Trade's
been a disaster for hundreds of millions of
people on this planet. You can't possibly
be for free trade. Can You David? Uh, every
single email I get that attempts to make that
economic analysis forgets that countries don't
exist in an echo chamber. The world didn't
start in 2019 or 2018 if we were just starting
nation states and setting up countries today
and economics and economies more importantly,
didn't already have hundreds of years of track
records. It would be a philosophical debate
over free trade versus protectionism and that
philosophical debate would have practical
implications. That's not the reality right
now. We are mostly engaged in a battle over
principles of free trade versus protectionism
that are only relevant in the theoretical
and and sort of philosophical world where
countries haven't existed for hundreds of
years. In the real world, we have 200 years,
almost 200 years of industrialization and
specialization.
So the way that Trump claims the tariffs will
work will simply not work. And this stuff
can be tough to explain clearly, but if you
don't get this, you can't possibly evaluate
these tariffs. The idea of putting tariffs
on Chinese stuff. To put it really simply
is if we make Chinese stuff more expensive
for American companies, American companies
will choose to buy American stuff to make
their products instead. So in a sense, you
put tariffs on Chinese stuff and it makes
American business more attractive, uh, for
internal production of different products.
But the problem is that our economy and those
of many countries are specialized. And specialization
is a concept where countries decide we can't
make everything. We can't make every product.
We're going to specialize in certain industries
or in certain materials or goods or job types.
And we've been specializing for a really long
time.
And in specialization it often makes sense
to trade with other countries even when you
have an absolute advantage in all goods or
in multiple goods, uh, relative to other countries.
Here's a, like just a super simple example
from economics one on one. You got to understand
this stuff. Imagine a simple world where you
have two countries and two products. Okay?
It's the u s in China and the two things that
the U and China can choose to produce our
sweet potatoes and cars. Okay. Really simple.
The United States might be better, might be
more efficient at making sweet potatoes in
China growing sweet potatoes we would say,
and at making cars in China, even if the US
has what's called an absolute advantage in
both sweet potato and car production, it can
still make sense to specialize and only make
one of those and to get the other one from
China, uh, as part of a, a trade policy because
of something called comparative advantage.
Even if we are in the absolute sense better
at making sweet potatoes and cars than China,
the ratio by which we are better at making
one over the other would be different than
that same ratio in China. In other words,
imagine a situation where in the absolute
we can make more cars per day than China and
we can make more sweet potatoes per day than
China. We might be significantly better at
making cars then sweet potatoes. Whereas China
might only be slightly better at making cars.
Then sweet potatoes and in that case it would
make sense for us to specialize, make cars
and get our sweet potatoes from China. We
have 200 years of this. There are switching
costs, there's competitive advantage, there's
economies of scale. Anyone who saying are
you for free trade or not because free trade
has been bad or protectionism is good or bad.
You're imagining this as a theoretical and
philosophical issue that doesn't relate to
the practicalities and in the meantime, Trump's
ignorance is growing the trade war. This is
bad for the economy. We knew it would be.
Trump has no off ramp from these escalating
tariffs and we're in very serious trouble
as the stock market and even Trump's own financial
adviser, Larry Kudlow are telling us